so it is cold it is miserable on a
Friday here in California and I was in
San Jose and I thought to myself why
even bother I should just do something
completely unproductive so I came up
here to Berkeley to do what any
emotional eater would do and that is
consumed massive quantities of chocolate
now one of my favorite chocolate makers
in the world sharpen burger here in
Berkeley so let's go kill my pancreas oh
here we are here with Brad and Brad
what's your job what's your full David
yeah my name is Brad Kinser and I am a
developer chocolate and just show you a
little bit about what we do here and
taste some chocolate all right so this
this is an excuse for me to eat massive
quantities of chocolate and have insulin
pour out my eyeballs and just have a
good time in the process those of you
who who follow me in the blog and noted
that my diet Saturday is my off day so
Saturday I'm gonna eat anything I wanted
it's Friday so I'm taking it a bit early
this week but generally at night I will
have a nightcap of a glass or two of
wine as I'm relaxing listening to music
as well as a couple of nibs of chocolate
usually the higher cocoa concentrations
but I'm gonna let you take the floor and
just walk us through what we have here
sounds good well this is our this is our
current lineup here we have a a number
of different chocolates here on our
right here we have our extra dark which
is an 82% cacao content now that that
cacao content really signifies the
amount of the percentage of this bar
that comes from the cocoa bean so 82% of
that is is from the cocoa beanie and
18% is is sugar and a small amount of
vanilla look ahead at this moment of
lesson so this is our darkest chocolate
if you're looking at you know pure cacao
cocoa punch then we have our 70% our 62
all right this is our this is and then
we have our milk chocolate a milk
chocolate is 41% cacao which doesn't
sound like a lot but it actually is
that's a very very dark milk chocolate
mm-hmm really gives a great combination
of what the milk flavor and also a
chocolate flavor right and then we have
a new bar that we just came out with
which is our milk almond with with sea
salt which has which is ice which is our
traditional milk chocolate with almonds
dusted with sea salt sort of that sweet
and sour or sweet and salty flavoring
and then we have a limited edition bar
that we came up with recently which is a
blend of several different very unique
beans from Trinidad
Grenada the Dominican Republic and also
Venezuela
so yeah this I saw earlier in the shop
and I was excited to try because this
this version over here the 70% is
actually what I use along with the
guitar that makes some good stuff but
the Scharffen Berger 70% is what Hayek
used to make truffles I took classes
with a chocolatier in Saratoga which is
a nice small town by the visiting we're
also great for motorcycle riding and I
have a lot of experience 70% but I'm
looking forward to to tasting the full
spectrum or at least taking us through a
tasting of chocolate I think most people
they they would be familiar with the
concept of wine tasting maybe they know
a few different types of wine sure
perhaps even tea they know if you
different have to tea it shop people
think of chocolate I think they might
think of dark and no chocolate but it's
really not much beyond that decision
sure and just just for the sake of
giving people a full idea
white chocolate
my understanding is named Shawn isn't it
it's the cocoa butter and or well it is
technically chocolate according to the
FDA okay but it's it actually had in it
is chocolate because it contains a
component of cocoa beans which is the
which is the cocoa butter right however
it doesn't have as you can tell it's
white it doesn't have the cocoa solids
which it loosely translated is really
the cocoa powder so it doesn't have a
lot of the components that are healthy
for you right and and it's oftentimes
very sweet okay cool well that's uh what
else do we have here so we see the
samples here but what are we looking at
it right here and then here we have we
just done these are some raw cocoa beans
from Madagascar mm-hmm
and then we have this here is some some
nibs from Madagascar this is from this
next one is from a farm in Trinidad and
then we also have a selection from deep
in the Guarani mountains of Venezuela
these beans had to come on horseback to
get to us now there's a long trip right
love that as well is it well it was very
I love the good available but getting
them out of the mountains would take a
while so they're it's a very generic and
the nibs are those just chips from the
coca leaf yeah essentially nibs our
cocoa beans that have been roasted and
then had the shell in it
okay so so you wouldn't want to chew on
those you wouldn't want to chew on these
but if you roasted them and took the
shell off
but you can see that there is a shell
sort of like a oh right skin shirt a
little bit harder and then inside of
there is actual though it's yeah where's
dad it's so sort of immediately being
the cotyledons of the scene so now
product developer right that's your
technical final yep product developers
at companies like Yahoo and other places
but I think being a product developer at
Scharffen Berger means something quite
different so what what is your job what
you actually do as a fuzzy doll today
well it's it's in general its research
and development so I work with several
other people in the company to source
beads so he actually traveled to
different countries and by the Google
team to work with the farmers to help
them to improve their quality of their
cocoa and then we are able to buy it
from them usually at a higher price
which is which is a great relationship
because we received higher quality beans
and they receive a higher price for them
so it's a really really beneficial
relationship so that's one component the
other component is actually making and
maintaining some of these blends here so
sharper murder we've always taken a
traditional look at chocolate in that
and we like to blend chocolate for a
number of reasons
it creates a more consistent and it also
can create a more complex chocolate
flavor profile so we stay blood you mean
different you be in two different
sources sure so be like a Meritage right
weird anyway why it's a blending Goliath
turkeys that cook up exactly cool our
founder John charcoal Burger King from
the champagne business where that's very
common as creating and developing
complex flavors he a number of different
communities sort of our is our Forte and
you can see here we have for instance
this bar here has has between 8 and 11
different music hello in any given time
and you know sometimes a certain being
will sort of might be less available at
a certain time of year so we'll have to
insert another another type of you and
therefore would in the constantly
changing but we have a flavor profile
that sort of locked in our heads